all right now mr battle for the soul of
the nation joe biden will use his prime
time political speech tomorrow to launch
more baseless smears and slander against
conservatives accusing them of being
threats to democracy but of course biden
sits by silently as his own party is
viciously attacking republicans pretty
much every second of every hour of every
day and failing white house press
secretary karine jean-pierre confirmed
earlier today that biden's speech will
be filled with more reckless rhetoric
and unhinged rage you know
like earlier in the week when he used
the word fascist
you know the president thinks that there
is an extremist threat to our democracy
the president has been clear as he can
be on that particular
piece when we talk about a democracy
when we talk about our freedoms
the way that he sees is the mag of
republicans are the most energized part
of the republican party
that extreme this is an extreme threat
to our democracy to our freedom to our
rights
where was joe speaking out against the
574 riots in the summer of 2020 but of
course the far left failures extend way
beyond washington because just a week
after california regulators
put forward a new rule phasing out gas
powered cars by 2035 guess what
california the golden state is now
telling electric car drivers avoid
charging your vehicles and mid-summer
blackouts as the state's far left energy
policy goes from bad to worst now this
is a preview of coming attractions of
new green deal socialism that biden and
the democrats want for the entire
country by the way even elon musk
probably against his own financial
interest because he sells electric cars
has said repeatedly we need to produce
more fossil fuel energy here with
reaction florida senator marco rubio you
know you really you can't you can't make
it up buy an electric vehicle pay 20
grand more uh forget about the mining of
mother earth with big heavy equipment uh
run by diesel fuel
manganese and cobalt and nickel and
other minerals
forget the fact that the electric grid
is mostly run on fossil fuels get the
vehicle but then don't charge the
vehicle you really can't make it up
senator
yeah look these the problem one of the
critical problems with left-wing
policies like you see coming from the
democratic party these days is that they
don't mesh with common sense and reality
in the real world right so they have
these policies now where we're going to
go all this you know battery-powered
solar panel we don't have the
infrastructure for that we're not
anywhere near that even though all the
tax credits in the world are not going
to change that number two a lot of the
materials that you need to build these
batteries and solar panels all that
comes from china so you're empowering
them and number three is what pointed
out today and that is we don't have the
charging stations and if we do they're
telling people not to charge the
electric cars meanwhile the 90 something
percent of the cars that are on the road
driven by real everyday americans they
require gasoline and we're not producing
more of it we're not providing more of
it we're doing things that are hurting
our economy and really hurting people's
pocketbooks
so now the president's going to give
this political speech tomorrow which i
find pretty interesting
talking about the soul of a nation
uh a guy that referred to half the
country pretty much as as semi-fascist
uh you know remember in his inauguration
speech he talked about unity so much for
that it almost sounds like are you or
have you ever been a supporter of
conservatism and donald trump that's
what it's beginning to sound like to me
senator
there's two things happening here the
first is they're criminalizing
opposition i said they're trying and
dehumanizing their opposition so this is
what they've been doing now for a while
if you recall last year when they were
doing this fake voter rights thing there
is no voter crisis in georgia for
example he gave a speech basically
saying that anyone who didn't support
the bill they wanted was a jim crow
segregationist which is absolutely
outrageous and absurd
then we saw the attacks against the
supreme court basically calling them
illegitimate that these weren't real
judges that these guys and we saw a guy
come halfway across the country and try
to kill a supreme court justice and
brett kavanaugh we've seen churches
vandalized we've seen pro-life groups
being attacked and firebombed the next
thing you see is any criticism you know
you criticize the fbi you get all these
new stories about unprecedented threats
to the fbi you criticize the irs a
couple days later the irs is saying oh
we're now being threatened in essence
they've now established the shield where
if you criticize them they will claim
that you're putting them in danger they
on the other hand do not criticize
republicans they try to dehumanize
defame and smear republicans by calling
not republican office holders republican
voters everyday people by calling them
semi-fascists last week in florida
charlie crist running for governor once
again here said he didn't want the
support of anyone who had voted or
supported ron desantis which is the
majority of the state in essence they
are no longer attacked this is the
distinction here they're not attacking
political leaders alone they are
attacking voters which in florida is the
majority of voters because donald trump
won the state by four points you know as
i have been digging into your opponent
val deming's record
it looks like she nearly votes for
pelosi 100 percent of the time i don't
know if the people of florida know that
she prays defunding the police which is
why i understand you got the
overwhelming majority of support from
law enforcement in florida uh called
violent riots correct me if i'm wrong a
beautiful thing
and said the crisis at our border which
is unprecedented a 30-year high uh
something that was uh a normal thing she
made all of those comments and what is
the exact percentage of the time she
votes with nancy pelosi
no it's 100 she's never broken from
nancy pelosi once in essence she would
be like electing nancy pelosi to the u.s
senate from florida but it goes further
than that and look she's flush with
money right democrats all over the
country are pouring money into her
campaign i heard ron johnson earlier
same thing here i need people's help my
website is marco rubio.com i ask if you
can help please do because we're going
to be outraged and outspent here from
the far left but today she goes on one
of these zoom calls that she likes to do
with small groups of liberals and she
said
inflation's not important let's put that
to the side let's not talk about
inflation that's not the biggest issue
that's not her top priority well that
just tells you how disconnected she is
from everyday people but more
importantly it tells you how radical the
democratic party's become on some of
these ideas but she's a radical rubber
stamp what can they run on they can't
run on the border certainly
will they claim success on that 40-year
high of inflation record high gas prices
a disastrous foreign policy we don't
have law and order they support the
defund dismantle and nobel
our school systems crt
age inappropriate materials being taught
in school what are they going to run on
senator
well she thinks val deming says that the
border crisis is nothing new there's no
big deal there she thinks inflation is
something we need to put aside in a
corner and not be focused on she clearly
isn't she tries to portray herself as a
you know law enforcement she was once a
police officer that's been a long time
ago in the last six years in congress
she's turned her back on the police
departments and law enforcement that's
why they've all endorsed me she's
actually helped the left attack them as
you pointed out so i think she's going
to run on what the left runs on a lot of
money the help of the mainstream media
and i guess calling republicans and
people who vote for them fascists
senator your seat is critical if
republicans have are to have any hope
of uh retaking the senate same with ron
johnson and we're going to be following
your race closely and people should not
take any race for granted i think you'd
agree with that
all right thank you senator hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else